welcome back a record number of
republican women won house elections in
november
shattering the left's portrayal of the
gop as a boys club
and stemming the tide of the media's
forecasted blue wave joining me now to
talk about the long lasting effects
of these winds is newly elected south
carolina congresswoman
nancy mace along with former austin city
councilwoman ellen troxclaire who's the
author of
step up how to advocate like a woman
which is a guide for right-leaning women
to run for office uh nancy mace there
you are
i saw you a couple of weeks ago on
another channel and i thought
that is a very cool lady and i want to
introduce her
to my audience as well so um welcome and
i'd love you to start by just telling us
your story of how you
got to where you are today yeah
now and thank you steve for having me on
tonight i really appreciate it this is
such a great and humble opportunity to
be part of this
very diverse and inclusive freshman
class my life has been a series of
second chances
ups and downs i've had as many failures
as successes and in fact
i dropped out of high school when i was
17 and my first job was as a waitress at
a waffle house on the side of the
interstate
and when i won this seat in november i
had my
my speech my acceptance speech in the
parking lot of that very same waffle
house where i got my start
and so i i joke i'm going from the
waffle house to the u.s house
but shortly thereafter i actually was
able to get into college and became the
first woman to graduate from the citadel
the military college of south carolina
21 years ago and so
it's not just democrat women that have a
monopoly on breaking glass ceilings
republican women and conservatives
we've been doing it all of our life and
it's really it's very humbling to be a
part of this story this year in such a
historic
election it's exciting
now ellen you've been fighting and
campaigning for all this and helping
people do it for a while now we talked
about that a few months ago
what's your reaction to the successes we
saw in november
i'm absolutely thrilled i mean i was
shocked when i
saw the statistics saying that out of
the 11 000 people
who have ever served in the united
states congress only 359
have ever been women that's three
percent 21 of our states have
never been represented by a woman in the
senate and so
it's time to change that it's time to
step up and do something about it and
that's exactly what these women are
doing
they it's it's not just women on the
left that have these amazing stories i
cannot wait for america
to share the stories of the trail
blazing women that we're
now going to have in congress
um and nancy what just tell us some of
the sort of issues that you particularly
want to be focusing on and fighting for
once you're once you're up there in in
congress yourself
right well we can see right now with
covet 19 that is on hearts and minds of
families everywhere
especially people who've lost their jobs
lost their businesses lost
their livelihoods south carolina as a
whole we've done a really good job of
balancing
keeping people safe and healthy with
getting back to work and our
unemployment rate hovers just over just
north of four percent right now but
there are many states that aren't taking
those similar
or same actions and their economies are
crumbling so
getting us through this pandemic is is
job number one
but also ensuring that you know as we
look at this and spending in the future
we haven't been holding each other
accountable and so i think you really
have to look at our budget look at
fiscal policy
look at the the rise in the national
debt and the annual the deficit that we
have every year
it's untenable and we've got to make
smart decisions in the future
with targeted reliefs really focusing on
those that need it most
and and getting our folks back to work
safely that's
extremely important as a state lawmaker
i'm known as being fiscally conservative
but also
i'm known for reaching across the aisle
i had a prison reform bill
signed into law in south carolina in the
middle of covid so
i would like to continue working on some
of these issues where i can find
some solidarity with members of the
democratic party and work on
environmental issues work on some social
issues prison reform criminal justice
reform things that we can agree on
and help our country move forward and
heal
that's so great i mean again you know
not just by being there but the way
you're talking about your role
just shattering these these kind of
false caricatures that are made against
republicans
um briefly what can we if someone's
watching
um and thinking yeah i want to run for
offers but you know i'm just nervous
about it you know there's so many
barriers in the way
um what are some of the practical what's
some of the practical advice you'd have
for
for women on the right who want to run
for office
the one thing that i want women to know
is that they just need to take action
they just need to believe in themselves
we need your leadership and if you don't
do it
who will if we care about the future of
this country if we care about protecting
the freedom that makes america so
exceptional
we have to have the right spokes people
to deliver that message we have to have
the right role models
for our young women to look up to so
this isn't about
you know vote for a woman just because
she's a woman it's about we have
outstanding women across this country
and those those stories are being told
in a relatable way
so now you have a foil to the aocs of
the world who
who can say you know i went to from
waffle house to the u.s
house and and they're the ones that are
going to have the policies
that are going to bring our next
generation of women
up and it's so it's believe in yourself
and even if it's scary even if it's
risky
just do it exactly like nancy mays did
and
and she's there and we're very very
excited to see it thank you both so much
for joining us see you soon